[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hey, everybody
and welcome to Talks at Google
at the Cambridge office.
Today we are very fortunate
to have Dan Lyons here
to talk about his book,
"Disrupted-- My Misadventure
in the Startup Bubble."
Dan's had a ton of jobs
throughout his life,
including technology
editor at "Newsweek,"
creator of the blog "The Secret
Life of Steve Jobs," which
many of you have read, and
the co-producer and writer
for HBO's "Silicon Valley."
This book, actually, focuses
on his most recent misadventure
as a marketing fellow at
HubSpot, a Boston startup.
Please join me in
welcoming Dan Lyons.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
I'm amazed that
you all are here.
But thank you.
I want to tell
you, first of all,
that I'm a huge Android fan.
I want to thank anybody
here who works on Android.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
I love Android.
I think despite all the BS
we hear about people changing
the world, I actually
think Android
is a product that
changed the world
and is still changing the world.
And I really
believe in it, and I
know that sounds stupid
and kooky like a drank
the Kool-Aid, and I
don't even work here.
I think it's a
remarkable product,
and I thank you all
for it every day.
And also everything else--
I've built my whole life
around Google products,
I realized at some point.
I have Gmail, Google Docs.
I mean, I think the last
10 years of my life--
I don't know how many
years of my life--
are all in Google Docs.
I mean, everything--
I use your calendar.
Basically my whole life is built
around stuff you guys make,
and I really appreciate it.
And I know also
that it's not easy,
not that I would have any clue
how to make anything you make.
But I'm sure it involves
lots and lots of hard work
to make even a small thing
work for so many people.
And what?
AUDIENCE: And the
first one's free.
DAN LYONS: And the
[LAUGHS] I don't really
have prepared remarks.
I can tell you a
little about myself
and answer any questions
you have about the book.
But in short, I was a technology
journalist for a long time.
I still kind of am.
I still once in a
while write a story.
And I loved being a
journalist, and I still do.
I just loved, loved
being a journalist.
It was, for me, probably what
your jobs feel like to you,
just I get up
every day and I get
to meet fascinating,
interesting, amazing people
and ask them questions.
And they actually answer them.
So I met Andy Rubin
once, which is
how I became a big Android fan.
I did a cover story in
"Newsweek" about Android.
And I was like, I can't believe
I get to meet Andy Rubin.
It blew my mind.
I went out to Mountain View and
all the other guys on his team.
And it was like
that all the time,
meeting fascinating, interesting
people from across all fields.
I ended up at "Newsweek."
I was the-- they called
it technology editor
but I was really just a writer.
"Newsweek" went through a
few changes, and as you know,
the media business was
stressed and under trouble.
So I ended up getting
laid off in 2012.
And I suddenly looked around
and realized I was 50 years old
or 51 and not only
was out of a job
and working in a company
that was downsizing.
I looked around and the
entire industry I was in
was blowing up.
And I did the thing you do.
You call all your friends.
And a bunch of guys
from "Newsweek"
had bailed out to "Time."
And I thought, oh, I'll
just call and go to "Time."
And they were like, no.
We've got nothing.
And then Forbes where I
had worked for 10 years
before "Newsweek" had
been trying to poach me
while I was at "Newsweek."
And I kept saying, naw, I don't
want to go back to Forbes.
So now, of course, I'd
love to go back to Forbes.
I called them up, and they said,
oh, yeah, man, dude, oh yeah.
We love it when
people come back.
Come on down.
And when I got there,
it was like, well,
we don't-- we don't
have any jobs.
But we can give you
like a contract,
and you can do eight
stories a year for us.
And was like, OK.
And it'll pay $32,000
with no benefits.
And I was like, oh shit.
Like this is way
worse than I thought.
This is much more
dire than I thought.
So suddenly I was
kind of scrambling.
I ended up going to run
a little tech blog in San
Francisco called "ReadWrite."
And I was commuting back
and forth from Boston.
I've always lived in Boston.
And that was a grind.
And it kind of for me like
the last straw for me.
Because I thought if this is
what media jobs have become,
I don't think I can do this.
And it's because it's really
about spinning that hamster
wheel and traffic
and catchy headlines.
And you don't ever have time
to really do a good story
or meet people.
It wasn't really what I
got into journalism to do,
what appealed to
me about journalism
in the beginning in college.
So I ended up
starting to think I'll
go try to work in the tech
industry and get in a startup.
And that'll be fun, and
I'll go for that ride.
And when you're a tech
journalist covering
these places like
Google, you always
feel like a kid with your nose
pressed against the glass,
looking into the candy store.
And it looks so cool.
I've never done
a scientific poll
so I have no data
to back this up,
but I think everybody
I know-- all my friends
who are tech journalists--
I think all of them
at one point or another
have thought about it
or interviewed or tried to
get a job or at least wondered
what it would be like.
It's sort of like if
you're a sportswriter
and you're covering
baseball, and you really
wonder what it would be like
to play on a sports team.
And it seems like it would
be more fulfilling than just
writing about it, the difference
being that you don't have
any chance of playing baseball.
You'll never be able
to play at that level.
But in tech companies,
there are still
roles that like a
journalist, in theory,
is sort of semi-qualified
for like PR or blogging.
I mean, we're not really
well-trained for anything,
and we're not
really house-broken.
I literally had a
recruiter talking to me
at one point when I was
trying to cross over
to corporate jobs.
And she said, well, nobody's
going to want to talk to you.
And I did that fake
Steve Jobs blog,
which was like really
a bullet in the head.
And she's like, well,
you're not house-broken.
That was really
the word she used.
I was like, really?
She's like, yeah, nobody
wants a journalist.
You guys are all obnoxious.
You're rude.
You don't have any manners.
So no, it's going
to be really tough.
But long story short,
I ended up going
to work at HubSpot, which is
here in Cambridge so I didn't
have to move out to the Valley.
And I kind of didn't want
to move to the Valley.
And it didn't go well.
The long story short,
save yourself the time,
the recruiter was right--
[LAUGHTER]
--like totally right.
It didn't go well and
it was largely my fault.
And it was essentially
the inability
to keep my mouth shut-- very
predictable consequences.
And there were other issues
that came up while I was there.
I was twice the age of the
average employee and not
by accident.
It turns out the
company really wanted
to build a culture
around very young people
and had set up a
culture specifically
to appeal to young workers.
I was there about six
months, nine months,
and wondering what's wrong?
This just isn't working out.
And one day the CEO
gave an interview
in "The Times," which for
a little company like that
is a big deal.
And in it he said,
well, we're trying
to build a culture specifically
to attract and retain
Gen Y-ers.
Because in tech,
things move so fast.
And gray hair and experience,
they're really overrated.
Really, you know,
no value there.
And I kind of gasped,
seriously, because I first
thought like, A, do people
really believe that?
And then the second beat
was, even if you believe it,
would you be stupid enough
to say it in the paper?
I mean, I wrote a piece
in LinkedIn this week,
and I said it's akin to saying
like, well, we really like
to hire heterosexuals
or white people
because white people
are good at tech.
We like those white people.
Even if you think it, you
wouldn't say it, right?
And the lesson I learned
was age bias was different.
You can't say that about race,
gender, sexual orientation,
but with age, in the Valley,
everybody's like, yeah,
that's totally true.
Yeah, it's totally true.
Yeah.
Old people suck.
And I was like-- I
was flabbergasted
by this, that it was just open.
And that sort of was the
beginning of the end for me
because I mouthed off
about it on Facebook
and got in all sorts
of trouble about that.
The other thing that
occurred to me about age
was that I don't know--
well, two things.
I don't know if there's
any other industry,
other than professional
sports, where people just
accept that at 35 or 40 you
should expect then-- you're
winding down.
You're 40.
I think that's insane.
I'm 55 now.
I think I'm better
at what I do slightly
than I was when I was 35.
My sister-in-law is a
surgeon at Stanford.
She's a colorectal surgeon.
She's 40 years old,
and she basically
just started her
career because she
did med school, a
residency, a fellowship,
spent years and years
having to learn first
all the basics of
colorectal surgery.
And now she uses robotic surgery
from, I think, it's Da Vinci.
And they're very
complicated machines,
and it's very important work.
And it's very
intellectually demanding.
And it's also very
physically demanding.
You're on your feet, and it
requires a certain amount
of dexterity and skill.
And you just can't do this
without years of training--
I was talking to her.
I visited her a
couple weeks ago--
and years of really
arduous training where
you make mistakes,
and the mistakes you
make sometimes kill people
or cause them to suffer.
And the only way we
can train new surgeons
is to put people
through this ringer.
And they're talking a lot in
that industry-- among surgeons
they talk about
grit and resilience
being now the key
markers of success,
not really necessarily
huge intellect.
Although, there's certainly
a lot of intellect required.
So it struck me.
Imagine if you told
surgeons, well, OK, 45.
You really just can't
operate anymore.
And I don't buy this idea that
they say in tech that tech
is somehow unique and
different and so special
and moves so fast that older
people just can't keep up.
Because older people
keep up in the law.
They keep up in medicine.
There are surgeons
who are operating.
I know airline
pilots they make them
stop flying at a certain point.
Anyway, so I found that
idea kind of flabbergasting
and I wanted to write about.
The other idea that
I found astounding
was that I really love
the tech industry.
I've spent my whole
life covering it.
And I don't think you could
cover something that you hated.
You could, but it would
be a miserable life.
I genuinely as a journalist
get excited and got
excited going on stories.
I went to Lawrence
Livermore and met
the guys who were trying to do
fusion energy which may or may
not ever work, but to me,
it's like you guys are insane.
It's so amazing.
You would take on
something so big.
Or what to CERN to the collider.
And again, it's
like you can't leave
human beings will
harness themselves
to these enormous endeavors
and try to make it work.
Or the supercomputing
people at Livermore I
did another story on.
And so you end up having this
deep love and appreciation
for this industry and
all the good things
it gives to the world.
And then it occurred to me
that this industry that's
so great in so many ways is
also probably the least diverse
industry on earth and is
kind of like a little bit
apologetic for it but is
also sort of proud of it.
And I found that strange.
And I found that was something
worth wrestling with in a book.
This makes it sound like my
book is really depressing
and serious where it isn't.
It's really a comedy.
So the original
idea for my book was
I worked in this environment.
It was a very kooky start out
where they want to be Google
but they can't
quite get it right,
so it's all Google but off.
But they're HubSpotty
instead of Googley.
And what's it mean
to be HubSpotty?
And this and that, and there's
a way of looking at the world.
And we're on this big mission
but we sell email spam.
But it was like, we're
changing the world,
and we don't sell email spam.
We sell anti-spam.
And it's lovable
marketing content.
And there's a lot of
euphemisms, a lot of jargon.
So I originally set out to write
a modern-day "Office Space,"
like the Mike Judge movie only
set in 2016 at this startup.
And the eyes in character
is the old guy who comes in.
He's just failing
and struggling.
And people look at you
like you're a ghost.
There was the one
guy older than me
at the company and
then everybody else
way, way, way, way younger.
Like I would hang
out with 35-year-olds
because those were
the old people.
It was the closest I could get.
So I thought that
would be a funny book.
And as I started
writing it, though, I
started wrestling with this idea
of well why is it like that?
Why are these
companies playgrounds?
And why do they have all
this bread and circus
and ping-pong
tables and parties?
It was more of a
frat house culture
than I think what
you guys have here,
but a lot of the
new startups I think
are very frat, bro culture.
And why does that exist?
And how did that happen?
And I started trying
to unravel that and get
at business models.
So the middle part of the
book is the boring part
you should just skip.
Those are the chapters
where all this comes up.
You can read the
beginning and the end.
But no.
A book that started off trying
to be funny and just a comedy
ended up becoming having a
little insight in the middle.
So that said, I would
be happy to talk
to you about those issues in
the book or about Fake Steve.
I think there's still some
people who remember the "Fake
Steve Jobs" thing.
And that was kind of a funny--
I had to go to give a talk.
My last book was a Fake Steve
book, and when it came out,
I went to Google Mountain View.
And it was an
interesting conversation
because I had done a lot
of jokes about Eric Schmidt
and Larry and Sergey and stuff.
Or I can talk a little bit
about "Silicon Valley."
I'm a very, very minor guy.
Oh, I forgot that
part of the story.
While I was at HubSpot, and
really, really not going well,
I thought, OK,
I'll stay one year.
I'd started in April.
I'll stay till next April.
Then I'll kind of find a
way to kind of ease out.
Like I knew by about the
holidays this isn't working,
but nobody's hiring
in the holidays.
So I'll just get through
Christmas and New Year's.
And I'll do some skiing.
And then about April,
it'll be about a year.
And I can go away
and no one will know.
Or they call it graduation,
if you graduate.
Sometimes it's a
forcible graduation.
Sometimes it's your own choice.
But there's always
a celebratory email.
Some guy gets fired
and it'll be like,
Derek just graduated,
and we all wish him
best of luck with
his superpowers
on his new super adventure.
And it's like great.
You just fired that guy.
It's OK.
You can just say we hated him.
He sucks.
He's out.
But one woman got fired after
four and a half years of doing
a lot of different jobs.
And she was an accomplished one.
She was 35.
She had done a lot
of good things.
And they just told her--
her boss just said, well,
your job doesn't exist anymore.
At "Newsweek" I could
see that, right?
OK.
That was bullshit
there too, by the way.
In the same conversation, the
"Newsweek" woman said to me,
they just want to
take your salary
and hire five kids
out of college.
And I was like, OK, that's real.
I get that.
But this place was growing.
But for some
reason, I don't know
if she pissed somebody off,
did something wrong, whatever.
Just four and a half years
in you have two weeks.
You can interview for other
jobs inside or just get out.
And of course no
one else is going
to hire her inside because
now she's pariah, right?
She's got the Mark
of the Beast on her.
So she leaves.
But on her last day, they
had a graduation party.
And she was like
having panic attacks.
She was in her car crying,
like I don't get this.
Why are they fucking with me?
Why are they doing this to me?
I was like, I don't know.
This is like a serious
like mind screw.
Total rant.
So in the middle
of this-- sorry.
So I'm waiting until April.
They send me to a conference
in Salt Lake City.
It was like the Adobe
Digital Marketing Summit.
And if you want to ever
be in a ring of hell,
go to the Adobe Digital
Marketing Summit.
[LAUGHTER]
Some of you probably work
in digital marketing, right?
It's OK.
I'm sorry.
It was crazy.
And I'm walking around.
It's in the Salt Lake
City Convention Center.
It's like a two-level place
with this big sort of atrium
with a ring around it.
And I was walking around,
looking down thinking,
if I throw myself off
this, would I die?
Or would I just be
turned into a vegetable?
Would I be paralyzed for life?
Because I don't want
to be a vegetable.
But if I knew I
was going to die,
I probably would just throw
myself off this bridge
right now.
And literally I'm walking
around, and I get this call.
And it's an agent in
Hollywood at the agency where
I signed back when I was--
"Fake Steve Jobs" got developed
into a TV show.
I sold a cable
show based on that
and I wrote a bunch of scripts
and sold it to a cable network.
And then it never got made.
But the scripts were
floating around,
and I had met a lot
of people out there.
And then a few years
later, "Silicon Valley" got
picked up by HBO.
And literally this guy says,
"Silicon Valley's" about
to start airing.
And if they get renewed,
they don't know.
But if they get
renewed, would you
want to come out to Hollywood
and work on a TV show?
And I was like, if you
knew where I was right now.
I'm in the Salt Lake
City Convention Center.
I'm watching like two rows of
schmucks going up and getting
food out of, you know,
those steamer trays
or like the meat you don't
know what it is and the gravy.
I was like, dude, yes, yes.
I don't care how much money
it is-- free, I'll do it.
I'm done.
I'll pay you.
Really, seriously, I'll pay you.
So they did get renewed,
and I thought great.
There's my way out.
I'll just give my notice.
It's only 14 weeks,
but I'll find
something else on the back
end, and that'll be great.
And then the company
said, no, no, we'd
like to give you
leave of absence
so we can say that one of our
guys is working on the show.
Like, they saw some
publicity opportunity in it.
Like, we really
had to have meeting
so we can talk about
how we can drive value
from your job at HBO.
I was like, what?
And really you can't.
You know, can our
CEO have a cameo?
Can you plug our
product on the show?
It was like, no,
we can't do that.
And me of all people.
Like, I'm like the
peon of the peons.
So I went on a leave of
absence, and I should never
have come back, but I did.
And then it got
really unpleasant.
And I lasted just
a couple months.
And I left.
And then I did go
back last season
for another summer of
writing on the show.
And I don't know if
I'll ever go back again.
I don't know if
I'll be asked back.
It's like every
year you don't know.
But one other
interesting thing is
last year Dick
Costolo left Twitter,
and I don't know
if you know this,
but he did comedy before
he was a business guy.
He was a stand-up guy.
He was in a pair
with another guy
and they did some comedy act.
So he happened to
meet them, I guess,
and said I would love
to work on the show.
So one day I went
into work on a Monday,
and there was only one chair
left at this big table.
So I sat down.
And I looked and I'm
like, that's Dick Costolo.
Like, I'd never met him before.
He's talking, talking.
And at lunch, he got lunch.
And I said, oh, are you sticking
around for the whole day?
Because usually guests just come
in for a half day and leave.
He's like, no, I'm
working here now.
I'm like, whoa, OK.
I'm working with Dick Costolo.
This is awesome, right?
And he was really, really funny
and really smart and clever,
like a really nice guy.
It was just the weirdest
experience ever.
So that is sort of
the end of, I guess,
what I could tell you about my
little bio or my little story.
But if you have any questions.
I'm supposed to talk a
little more, but it's 2:30.
We can just have questions, if
you want to ask about the show
or about Fake Steve or
about god forbid the book.
I'm happy to talk,
have a conversation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So.
I haven't read the
book yet, but I think
I have a relevant question.
So in order to get
people motivated,
you like to give them these big
goals, like a Hadron Collider
and so on, so forth.
And you talk to them
about the big goals,
and you present them.
We have our weekly
meetings, our TGIFs
where we see the great
stuff that Google's doing.
On the other hand, 60,000
people, some of them
are doing really
repetitive, boring tasks.
And so the question
is, to what extent
is it a good thing to be
creating the illusion, if you
like, or the view that
everyone's important,
everyone's doing
something important,
we're all doing great stuff?
It's an illusion.
But the opposite is
a sort of cynicism
that you don't want
to get into either.
So it reminds the
anecdote of the guy who
visits the Kennedy Spacecraft
Center, whatever it's called,
Cape Canaveral, and asks
the janitor what his job is.
And he says, we're
sending a man to the moon.
The janitor's saying this.
So how do you balance
this illusion building
and euphemisms?
You talk about digital
marketing and email
spam-- I'm sure they didn't
call it email spam internally.
DAN LYONS: No lovable
marketing content.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
So what's the right balance?
How do you deal with that?
DAN LYONS: Yeah.
It's a very good question.
And I'm sure that's what
companies wrestle with,
and I'm sure that's why
a lot of the rhetoric
and those euphemisms exist
because nobody wants to call it
what it is, in some cases.
I don't know.
I think there was a time
when you could just say
I have a job, and I go to work.
And I do my job, and I get paid.
And I go home.
I mean, for most
people, it wasn't
required that their
life have a big mission.
But somehow that's
become a thing now,
that everybody has to feel
that they're on a mission.
I don't know.
Maybe you just do what
companies do and say that.
I have a question.
When you do the TGI Fridays,
does everybody in the satellite
offices tune in?
Does everybody go to
a room and watch it?
Or you watch it at your desk?
AUDIENCE: Next day.
DAN LYONS: Oh, it's taped and
you just watch it the next day.
AUDIENCE: There is a livestream.
DAN LYONS: Because it's late
in the day West Coast time.
What time is it at?
AUDIENCE: 7:30 here.
DAN LYONS: Oh, OK.
And you guys aren't here
at 7:30 on a Friday?
Do they know that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, OK.
So I always wondered that.
And they shifted it at one
point to a different time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
It's on Thursday.
DAN LYONS: Oh, it's on
Thursday nights now at 4:30.
Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: So we
get it [INAUDIBLE].
DAN LYONS: So you
watch it on Friday
when you come into the office.
But do people get
together in this office
and watch it as a group?
AUDIENCE: A lot of people do.
DAN LYONS: Oh, they do.
AUDIENCE: Here, yeah.
DAN LYONS: Here, oh,
it's in this room.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's--
DAN LYONS: So about this many
people would be watching?
AUDIENCE: No--
DAN LYONS: No, all
right, all right.
OK.
I've just always wondered that.
You know, I don't know.
I don't know how you get people
motivated to work like that.
I just think there's
a certain amount
of dishonesty or foolishness
that I found to it.
Again, I'm super naive.
I sort of think of
Google as a place
that legitimately
is doing big things
or at least trying
to do big things.
I still love the balloon
with the Wi-Fi thing.
Is that floating
around anywhere?
It is, right?
I mean that's--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN LYONS: They're
using it, right?
I mean, it's cool.
So I always felt like
if you were at a place
where like-- if you were at
NASA and the ultimate goal
was to put a guy on the moon,
even if your role was small,
then you could still
be proud of that.
My dad spent his whole
life at divisions of AT&T.
And there's a big factor
in Massachusetts where
I grew up, in North Andover.
And he for a while was running
one of the shop floors.
And the job, literally,
was-- I think they
were before circuit boards.
And they would actually
hand wire boards.
They would like-- you know.
And I remember thinking that's
got to be the worst work.
And it was basically
assembly line work.
And I don't think
anybody dressed it
up as like we're changing
the way people communicate.
It's like, no, you're
making phone crap.
But it paid well, and
there was over time,
and people were happy to do
that work for the paycheck.
It was considered, where I grew
up, a really good place to get
a job.
It was a secure job,
and it paid well.
That's a long way of
saying I don't know.
Sorry.
When in doubt, just bullshit.
No, I think companies
struggle with that.
I'm taken aback by it.
I think it started with
Facebook, where they
were like changing the world.
And I guess, in a way, like
now I sort of think they have.
I used to think they
were ridiculous,
that it was just
like the biggest time
waster in the world, Facebook.
And now I find I
spend all day on it.
But yeah, I think
everybody saw that,
and it's maybe almost
something that investors expect
a startup to be able to say
we're disrupting xyz industry,
and it's a trillion
dollar industry.
We're going to have
this much of it.
And we're changing the world.
And that phrase, we used that
a lot on "Silicon Valley."
We make fun of that a lot.
But, you know, some
companies really are.
I think Tesla's really
changing the world.
I would probably love
to be a peon at Tesla.
I think that would
be pretty cool.
I'd love to be a
peon at Google too,
if you-- no one will
ever hire me again.
But no, I mean, I think to have
a small role at a big place
doing important
work would be cool.
It'd be interesting.
Like the old Bell Labs, I
visited those guys a few times.
And I thought, like, man, to
be even a tiny part of this
must be very, very cool.
It must be meaningful.
But I don't know.
Maybe day-to-day it isn't.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: I think your
comments on the youth
culture in technology
are interesting and true.
DAN LYONS: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: One of things
I've wondered about that,
though, is if things
go well, young people
turn into old people.
And I'm wondering--
DAN LYONS: Yeah, right,
exactly, exactly.
If things go well.
I like that you prefaced that.
Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I
really wonder what
the people who are
enforcing youth culture
think they're going to
do when they're 45 or 50.
DAN LYONS: Right.
AUDIENCE: 35 [INAUDIBLE] maybe.
DAN LYONS: I wrote this think
in LinkedIn this week that's
gone crazy.
I've had like more than
1,000 comments about age.
And it really struck a nerve.
But I got a an email from
a guy in San Francisco.
Now he's not technical
but he works in tech
as a writer/blogger kind of guy.
He's 32.
And he said, I'm
already freaking out,
like I'm too old because the
people right out of college
are way younger than me.
And I feel like I'm getting
aged out-- at 32, right?
The other thing I
always think about
is, you know the
famous Mark Zuckerberg
quote when he was like 20?
He got up on stage and said
young people are just smarter.
And I wonder if he's going
to feel that way when
he's 40 and 50, right?
Maybe.
It may be that they want
to hire young people
for certain reasons
other than the fact
that they themselves are young.
But I do wonder if
that attitude will
change as these companies
grow up and mature.
I have the same fear.
Then you feel like--
because a lot of people
don't like this book.
There was an excerpt
in "Fortune,"
and it's kind of making
fun of the [INAUDIBLE].
It was a pretty funny excerpt.
But a lot of people
didn't like it.
And one guy said, here's
my review of the book.
And it's a picture
of Grandpa Simpson
and it says, "Old
man yells at cloud."
And again, you feel like you're
the old guy ranting around
like, (OLD MAN VOICE)
these kids these days.
And it's like, no.
I mean, I think
people of all ages
are cable doing great things.
It's the reverse that I think.
After 40 somehow you're useless.
And I wonder, yeah,
when they get to be 40--
are they all buying into a world
view that says, you know, yeah.
Your career's only going
to-- don't worry about it.
When you turn 30, you'll
deal with it then.
But how?
I don't know.
That is one of the big problems.
You're a millennial.
AUDIENCE: Not quite, thank you.
DAN LYONS: Oh, really?
OK, thank you.
Sir, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I haven't
read the book yet either.
Maybe this is-- I'm just
asking you to talk about what's
in the middle chapters.
But you kind of
implied, I think,
that the sort of frat
culture of a lot of startups
contribute to and reinforces
the lack of diversity.
And how do you unpack
and reverse that?
DAN LYONS: Yeah.
That's a really good question.
And I do think
those are related,
that the frat, bro culture is--
and this idea of culture fit.
When I interviewed at
HubSpot, that was one
of the first things they said.
Like, we like
culture fits, someone
we want to go have a beer with.
That's who I want
to hire, people
who I want to have
a beer with, which
is sort of the euphemism for
people who are just like me.
So it actually creates
a lack of diversity.
It's the opposite of diversity.
It's a uniformity.
It's a filter bubble.
I think the only way
it gets reversed--
because right now
Silicon Valley will
pay lip service to
diversity, at least when
it comes to race and gender.
They don't really
do much about it.
But every year the
reports come out.
Apple, Google, Facebook put
out their diversity numbers.
I did a search for this,
and the headlines all
show-- new report
shows little progress.
Next year, new report
So I think this is
incredibly cynical.
And I don't think it
applies to Google,
but I think maybe a lot
of these startups that
are very bro-like cultures.
I think if you gave the
bros a shot of truth serum,
and they said what they really
thought, they would say,
yeah, we have to say that stuff.
But they believe in their minds
that the optimal arrangement
is a bunch of bros working in a
company who think the same way.
And then that gives them energy.
And I think they
actually think this
is the optimal arrangement.
We're going to get the
best financial payoff
if we do it this way.
Anything we do about
diversity will slow us down,
will make us less nimble.
It's just an impediment.
And yeah, we'll do as little
of it as we can to get by.
But we won't really do it.
We don't really
believe it'll work.
And I think the only
way for change to come
is for these guys to become
convinced that it's actually
in their economic interest,
that it actually makes company
better and stronger, that
it's smart business, not
just a nice thing to do.
Because I think the ultimate
cynical response from Silicon
Valley is, like, we're not in
the business of being nice.
I'm not in the
business of trying
to help you or help
women or help-- no.
You take care of yourself.
It's a meritocracy out here.
And I'm in the business to
make as much money as I can.
And I'm going to
do whatever I can
to make the most money in
the least possible time.
I actually think
that's the problem.
And I think they have
the wrongheaded idea
that lack of diversity
equals success financially.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: So not to
distract from the book,
in your experience as
a technology writer,
in the things you've
covered, is there
anything that
stands out as being
particularly bizarre or
foolhardy or brilliant and
successful?
DAN LYONS: You mean of things
that I covered and wrote about?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAN LYONS: Well, I wrote about
the first dot com bubble.
I was at Forbes at the time.
And I remember it
lasted so long,
or it seemed to at the time,
that I started to doubt myself.
I started thinking maybe
these guys are right.
Maybe the laws of gravity
don't apply anymore.
Maybe the markets have changed.
Economics have changed.
Trees grow to the sky.
I remember this moment
where I thought,
like, I'm the wrong
one, again, all
of us who are cynical
on the outside saying
this is ridiculous.
But that was a fun period.
Ironically looking back
on that period now,
it was a great
time for magazines
because all those companies
raised lots and lots of money.
And they bought, what, Sun
computers, Oracle database,
routers from Cisco,
and EMC storage.
That's where they
spent all their money.
And then they
bought ads for hype.
So we got all the ad money.
And so we all thought in the
media business this is great.
Boy, business is booming.
So I think we were all
very foolish in those days.
And it's hard not to be
foolish when you're benefiting
from the foolishness.
You're having a great time.
But no, I wrote about a lot of
things and met a lot of people
that I thought were
really interesting
and doing amazing,
amazing things.
I always felt, for
example, Microsoft
was a much better company
than they got credit for.
I think Ballmer made
a lot of mistakes,
and he missed a lot of things.
But, boy, they've built
this enterprise business
that really phenomenal.
And just the people I met
at Microsoft over the years
were always really, really
nice, smart, dedicated people.
Engineers, especially,
were always the best.
You very rarely get
to meet real engineers
when you're a journalist.
You're very much
kept on the outside,
and you get brought in
and given a canned thing.
And the person's
been media trained.
So you realize you're always
kind of working from a script
that the company has written.
But when you can meet real
engineers, they're the best.
They're always like great
people, very cynical.
You know what I mean?
They're a lot like
journalists in some ways.
They're really wise asses
and great sense of humor.
And I always loved
that Microsoft
had this engineering culture,
especially in the early days.
And the same thing at
Google, I mean the best thing
about being a tech journalist--
and probably a lot of you
have worked at different places.
You work in the tech
industry, there's
a lot of amazing, really
cool, really nice people
who are just fantastic to meet.
So that was the
best thing about it.
I mean, I have friends that
I've been in touch with,
like a PR guy that
I met on a story,
and we became friends
for-- I was just
trading email today with a
woman who did PR at Dell in '99.
And we got to be friends,
and we're still friends.
And she doesn't work in tech
anymore-- just really, really
fantastic people.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Don't
mean to stop you.
I love the Fake Steve Jobs.
I was wondering
if there's things
that happened since that
ended that you really
wanted to write about or
talk about in that voice?
DAN LYONS: Yeah,
not so much lately,
but there was a time
when I really missed it.
It was very addictive
for me doing that blog.
There were, in fact, a
lot of times along the way
early on when I really thought
I should stop because I thought
this is disastrous.
And I would find I couldn't.
Then something would happen
and it'd be like, ohh.
And there was a time when
I thought-- I stopped
when Steve got really sick.
I was actually big Apple fan.
I find the cultiness and
the weird mind control stuff
hilarious.
Same thing at HubSpot-- I
find it hilariously funny.
But I loved the products,
and I admired him.
So after he died, though,
there was a time when I really
thought about bringing him
back as Dead Steve Jobs,
which is terrible, right?
I mean, it's so wrong.
And he either gets a laugh or
people like-- like that woman
covering her face.
It's like oh shit.
Like there's a couple people
really not looking happy now.
I'm sorry.
And I didn't mean it
in a disrespectful way.
But I had this idea.
In the "Fake Steve
Jobs" blog, he
was sitting in
the Lotus position
with the bong and a MacBook.
And I actually had an artist
do a version of that only he
had wings and he was
on a cloud and he had
a harp and a MacBook, right?
And the idea was
he's gone to heaven.
And he's in the afterlife.
And he's really pissed because
he got taken too early.
And he's also really pissed
because he hates all the stuff
Tim Cook is doing.
And I thought it could be
really cool to have him
up there going, no,
no, no, not the watch!
Not the watch!
Or, that's never going to work!
No one's going to buy it!
Or whatever.
I just thought Apple in some
ways has changed without him.
And I thought that
could be funny.
I even thought there could be
a TV show not about Steve Jobs
but about that idea.
Like have you even
seen the movie,
it's with Albert Brooks and
Meryl Streep, where they--
AUDIENCE: "Defending Your Life."
DAN LYONS: What is it?
"Defending Your Life."
Yeah.
And it's set in the
afterlife, and they die.
And they go to a place
that's a lot like Google.
It's really beautiful
and perfect.
And everything's calm,
and there's food.
And it's wonderful.
They land in the Googleplex.
And before you
can get to heaven,
you have to go in
like in a courtroom
and defend all the shitty
things you did in your life
that you thought no one saw
but they saw because they have
video of everything, right?
But there's never
been a TV show where
the guy is in the afterlife.
I thought that could be
half-- you could do a TV show.
It's a CEO, gets hit
by a bus one day.
Or maybe make it more like
Ari Gold in Entourage,
like kind of an
intense character.
And he gets whacked,
hit by a bus.
And bam, he's dead.
He's in the afterlife.
And his company that
he loves-- and he
wasn't ready to leave it.
He has to watch someone
else screw it up.
And I thought that could
be a fun show-- half
of it set in the afterworld.
He's meeting other famous dead
people who turn out to be jerks
or whatever.
Gandhi turns out to be
a real prick, whatever.
You can have stuff like that.
And then he could even appeared
to Tim Cook like in dreams
or in his room.
I had one idea where Bill Gates
is in like Dubai in a room.
He's got security.
He thinks he's safe.
And he wakes up in the
morning, and dead Steve
is sitting in the corner in
the chair just looking at him.
He's like, whoa, Jesus!
And then Steve is there to have
a reckoning with Bill Gates.
Anyway.
I literally pitched this and
got exactly this response.
Like, no!
We're not making a
show about a dead guy
who appears to people, like no.
[LAUGHS] And yet, even
now as I pitch it to you,
I still believe in it.
I still want to make that show.
So yeah, I did
have this yearning.
It was hard to give it up.
It really was.
It was very, very hard.
And I don't so much anymore.
Long answer, sorry.
Sorry, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
about the reporting
process for this book.
Because when you're a reporter,
people know you're a reporter.
You go to campus.
You're wearing a badge.
At what point in the process
where you're an employee
did the light bulb go on
like, OK, I'm doing a book.
And the people around me
maybe don't know that,
and you're like scribbling
notes from a meeting.
Or [INAUDIBLE] all
done afterwards?
DAN LYONS: It was
all done afterwards.
I wasn't really taking notes.
I was paying attention.
And I take notes as a
habit, like in meetings
because I never remember
what's in a meeting.
So I tend to sit in meetings
and just type and type and type.
Because it's just
by force of habit.
My whole life I've been
sitting across from people
typing or writing notes.
But it's a good question.
And I don't really
have-- I mean,
I did do reporting after I left
that wasn't to do with HubSpot,
that had to do with
calling up people
in the industry for
perspective on the bubble
or compensation, other CEOs
or venture capitalists.
I think of it more as like
a memoir of my time there,
and I'm remembering things
that happened when I was there,
like a crazy meeting.
There was an incident
with Teddy bear.
Yeah, see.
This is one of the moments where
I knew I don't belong here.
So about three months
in, we got a note saying,
you know, they're very good
like promoting on social.
You get a note saying
the CTO, the founder,
just published a new
article on LinkedIn Pulse,
and we've got to all
go online and all spam
it and all tweet it and get
everybody to drive traffic
to that blog, that post,
And my feeling is like if a post
is good it will get traffic.
And you can't tweet a
turd to your success.
You can't.
I don't believe in it.
I don't think that works.
And I think if it's
a great post it
finds-- a great piece
of content, let's say,
will find an audience.
And so I kind of find that
whole thing ridiculous.
But I say, OK, I'll do it.
And I went and looked
at the post, though.
And the post said,
we really believe
in solving for the customer.
The customer is so important.
We want the customer
present at every meeting.
So we have an empty chair.
We put the empty chair-- every
management team meeting I have,
I have an empty chair.
And the empty chair
is the customer.
I don't know if they
talked to the chair.
But we consult the empty chair.
But that wasn't enough.
So I got a Teddy bear.
Now I bring the Teddy
bear to meetings.
And he had a picture.
This was on LinkedIn.
He was really proud of it,
like with the CMO sitting next
to a Teddy bear.
And the Teddy bear has a Red
Bull, looking all pissed off.
And he's like, this is
Molly the Teddy bear.
And she comes to all
of our meetings now.
And I'm like, this is nuts.
This is crazy.
But everybody else around
me thinks it's cool.
And literally the guy-- we sat
screen to screen like this,
was a former Googler.
He had been here for
like just three years,
like an entry level ad sale guy.
And he was kind of cool.
So I leaned over to him and
I was like, dude, dude, hey.
What?
He's like what?
I'm like, did you
read that article?
He's like, yeah.
And there's like people all
around, so you had to be quiet.
And I was like, the
Teddy bear thing.
Did you read that?
He's like, yeah, yeah.
I thought it was really good.
I'm like, you thought
that was good?
And he's like, yeah.
I was like, that's crazy.
He's like, no, no,
no, well, you know,
startups are really-- they're
really eccentric and kooky.
And that's how we are, man.
And I was like, wait a minute,
when you were at Google,
if Larry Page came out and said
that he was bringing a Teddy
bear to meetings, you're telling
me that everybody at Google
would just be like, hey, great.
That's awesome.
Let's just all have Teddy bears.
He's like, well, no,
Google's different.
I was like, no,
because that's insane.
No matter where you are,
carrying a Teddy bear
to meetings is crazy.
So what amazed me was
not just the Teddy bear
but the fact that
no one else had
a problem with the Teddy bear.
And it wasn't like
we all think it sucks
but we don't dare say anything.
It was like they had
really bought in,
like this is awesome.
All I know is in any
news room I worked in,
if the managing editor-- and
there are managing editors
out there who probably would
bring a Teddy bear to sit
in as, this is the reader.
Think about what
the reader wants.
That person would
be mocked forever.
They would be just mocked
mercilessly forever.
Everybody would get Teddy bears.
We'd leave Teddy
bears in his office.
We'd stab Teddy bears.
I mean, it's terrible.
You'd do horrible things
to the guy's Teddy bear.
You'd put him a
noose like, [GROANS].
But nobody did that.
It was just the
most amazing thing.
Anyway.
[INAUDIBLE] questions.
Yes, sorry.
My point is I was just
observing stuff like that,
and I remembered
that, going like,
oh, I remember the
Teddy bear thing.
So how do you describe that
and make it like a scene
so it's funny?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Kind of seguing back.
Thank you for writing
the Fake Steve Blog.
DAN LYONS: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: It was a joy.
I was surprised to hear
that somebody reacted
as if you weren't house trained
for writing that, I think
is what you said.
DAN LYONS: Well, and she
meant journalists in general.
She just meant companies
don't like to hire journalists
because you're--
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
DAN LYONS: --kind of, yeah.
AUDIENCE: For those
who don't remember,
you were kind of unmasked.
You wrote in secret
for quite awhile.
And when you were unmasked,
I didn't have the impression
that you were doing
anything really wrong.
It seemed like a subversive
kind of journalism, actually.
DAN LYONS: It had
become that, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because I remember
certain entries that you had,
like talking about meeting
with music executives
to create iTunes and
that kind of stuff,
it seems like you
couldn't have written
the same way if you had just
written an article yourself.
DAN LYONS: Right.
You needed the shift
of the character.
Yeah.
And it became journalism
because I originally started
just writing little jokes.
I originally started
writing it because I wanted
to learn how to use Blogger.
It didn't have anything
to do with content.
But I needed something.
And I tried WordPress.
I tried TypePad.
And then I wanted
to use Blogger.
And so, I'll just do a fake CEO.
Because like Robert
Scoble was always
writing about how all
CEOs should have blogs.
Remember the guy at
Sun, Jonathan Schwartz
had a CEO blog, which I
thought was like the worst idea
ever, like the CEO
should have a blog.
But you could only go so far
with like jokes about yoga
and stuff with Steve Jobs.
And then finally I had
to have something for him
to write about.
And I thought, oh, what if
he's covering technology?
He's like a journalist.
He's like pontificating
on stuff that's happening,
not even in his own place.
Like he used to rail
about open source
because I used to
cover open source.
And I was obsessed with it.
And so he would be making
fun of those guys, which
was not in character for
Steve Jobs at all, really.
I mean, although he
probably had his opinions.
But yeah, it was a
kind of journalism.
In fact, toward the end,
there was a really good one.
I'm still kind of semi-proud
of this where the CEO of AT&T
came out and said
something about all these--
the iPhone was
fairly new, and he
was saying that these iPhone
users are using too much data
and they're clogging
up our network.
We've got to find a
way to choke them back.
They're taxing the network.
And so I had Steve Jobs go
on this rant like, look.
Like we created this great phone
that everybody wants to use.
This is like you're the record
label, the pressing plant,
and someone just gave
you "Meet the Beatles."
And there's so
much demand for it.
And you're like
goddammit, these people.
I wish they would stop
listening to this music,
like I can't keep making
these stupid records.
He's like, build
out your network.
And then I went
on this long rant,
and it kind of went viral.
And then as a joke--
that was on a Friday.
It went crazy over the weekend.
I thought, oh, I've
struck a nerve.
Time to hit again.
And so on Monday I get up
and said Steve Jobs says,
well, I'll tell you what.
All the engineers
here are so pissed
because like we worked
so hard on the iPhone,
and then they're trying to
choke it back and make it worse
experience.
We've come up with an idea.
This Friday at 12 o'clock,
12:00 noon Pacific time,
everybody get on your
iPhone at the same time.
Do something really
data intense,
and let's just take
down the whole network,
like we're going to call
it Operation Choke Hold,
and we're going to destroy
the AT&T network, right?
Ha, ha, ha.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is a true story, right?
And I'm working at
"Newsweek" at the time,
and AT&T, it turns out,
is our largest advertiser.
But I don't know this, right?
I don't know this at all.
So I put this thing out there.
They're going to
think it's a joke.
I forgot all about it.
But then someone starts
a thing, and they're
going to actually do this.
And next thing I know,
people are writing about it,
like Operation Choke
Hold Friday at noon.
This is a thing.
And like AT&T, I think they
issued a statement about it.
And next thing I know,
I swear to God, it's
on Wolf Blitzer-- Wolf Blitzer.
I have a clip of him
like, they're calling it
Operation Choke Hold.
Techies are threatening
about taking down-- it
all started on this
satirical blog.
And I'm like, oh shit.
Like, I'm in such
trouble, right?
And I remember saying to people,
I don't think it'll work.
I don't think you can take
down the network if everybody
gets on at the same time.
But I don't know.
I mean, I don't know.
Maybe it will.
Of course it didn't do anything.
Then I started doing stories.
Because I'm like, OK.
Fine.
Let's be pissed about this.
So I started looking at how
much money they were taking in
in data revenue.
And it was huge, like this.
And how much were they
spending on Capex?
Like this.
So I start writing these
articles saying, you SOBs.
Like, you're making
all this money on us,
charging us for data, but you
won't build out your network
to support what we want to do.
And then I felt like I hope
we do take down the network.
So it didn't go down.
And Friday in the afternoon I
get this call from my editor
at "Newsweek."
She's like, hey.
I'm like, hey, how are you?
I haven't talked
to you all week.
What's going on?
She's like, nothing
much, how are you?
I'm like, ah, not bad.
And I said, have you heard
about this Operation Choke Hold
thing?
She's like, oh yes.
So apparently AT&T was lighting
them up all week, telling them
you've got to fire this guy.
We're going to pull all our ads.
But they said it's not our blog.
It's his crazy
thing on the side.
But that was one where I
actually thought-- and then
AT&T starts putting
out press releases.
We're building out network here.
We're adding this in Cincinnati.
We're building out this.
And I was like, OK, so there
was a little bit of activism
there that maybe did
a little tiny bit.
Anyway.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
What does disruption
mean to you?
You use it in the
title of your book,
and you apply to yourself.
We hear this word today in
every context of society,
and especially
technology and society.
What does it mean to you?
And also relatedly, in your
long life in Massachusetts,
in Cambridge, perhaps, have
you seen how the dynamics
within the companies
that you're describing
actually affecting or
possibly disrupting
the community's regular
day-to-day life in Cambridge?
DAN LYONS: I haven't
seen that, and I've
lived in and around Boston
for on and off since the 80s.
Well, I grew up
in Massachusetts.
I haven't really seen
disruption in the community,
but I think people who
are closer to Cambridge
would say that they have.
I don't know.
But yeah, I thank
you for that question
because that was the sort of
pun of the title was that we
talk a lot about disruption.
When you're a tech
journalist, it's
one of those words you use so
much you try to stop using it
because it's so easy to just
say they're disrupting this.
They're disrupting that.
And we all talk
about disruption.
I'm not sure.
Did it come from
Clayton Christensen?
Does anybody know?
Is it from "The
Innovator's Dilemma"?
Is that where it comes from?
But in my case, it
was that my life
got disrupted by, oddly enough,
in a way, by the internet.
"Newsweek" got destroyed
by the internet.
I mean, the media
business got upended
or disrupt-- classic disruption,
right-- of a monopoly business,
disrupted by this change.
So I wanted it just to be a
pun or a double meaning thing.
And then I thought, I'm
leaving the disrupted side
of the world, and I'm going
to go work for the disrupters.
We're going to be
the change agents.
And in many ways, they were.
There were a lot of
really smart, cool people
who had new ideas
about media there.
So mainly for me it was just
about my life being disrupted.
There's is slightly larger
aspect of it, which is that--
and I write about this
in the book, --in 2011,
while I was at "Newsweek,"
they had a story
called "Beached White Males."
It had a picture of a guy
in a suit, a business guy
in a suit with gray
hair, faced down
on the beach with the waves.
He's like dead, right?
And if he's not dead,
like almost dead.
And it was this whole story
about how in the 2008 and 2009
crash and that whole thing,
that the people hit hardest
were men my age like in
the 40s then, 40s, 50s, who
were getting knocked out.
They had risen to
a certain level.
They're getting
paid pretty well.
And they were all
getting wiped out.
That's who companies
were getting rid of.
And they were also finding it
impossible to find new jobs.
There was this
generational thing.
And I remembered at
the time because I
was working in "Newsweek,"
and I remember reading it.
And there was a sense of glee
inside there at "Newsweek."
The people running
"Newsweek" thought
this was really kind of funny.
And I remember
thinking, in a way,
well, maybe I'm immune to this.
But then two years later, I
became a beached white male.
There I am like 51 years old.
The other meaning
of disrupted to me
was that I think there's a
generation of people who began
our careers still thinking
that the social contract
between employers
and employees was
the one that our
parents had, where
it's like my dad went to AT&T
and worked his whole career,
retired with a pension.
When I began my career, we
sort of had those expectations.
And people coming out and
people coming into the workforce
now don't have
those expectations.
They have bought into a
whole new view of work.
But my generation
got caught in the
middle with the
old expectations--
20th century expectation but
we're in the 21st century.
So I think there's a
generational disruption
happening too that's caused
by the internet, caused
by changes in-- well,
the internet has
changed everything we do.
So I think that has disrupted
industries all over the place
and caused a whole generation
of people to be sort of lost.
And I'm part of that
lost generation.
AUDIENCE: So I
want to invite you
to talk about
venture capitalists
a little bit in the
remaining one minute.
To get that started,
my sense is that a lot
of the people in venture capital
are guys in their 40s or 50s
who made it in high
tech and think that they
did that for a reason.
But do you think it's
a functional thing
that we had these venture
capitalists backing
all these startups?
Do you think it's dysfunctional?
Do you think it's
[INAUDIBLE] problems?
Helping things?
DAN LYONS: I think there's
a bubble in venture capital.
I don't have numbers.
I should have looked
these up for the book,
and I should have included this.
It would be good data to have.
Just the number of people who
consider themselves either
venture capitalists
or angel investors now
compared to 10 years ago,
but I guess the number
is way, way bigger today.
There's just a lot of people
who now consider themselves
investors.
What I do touch
on in the book is
that there was this change
that came in the last 2012,
I think, in the
JOBS Act, where they
made it easier for
mom and pop investors
to get into syndicates
and invest in startups.
So you had an even
bigger influx of money.
The government loosened up rules
so that more regular people
could invest.
So I do think there are
a lot of people playing
at being venture capitalists.
And I'm not sure if that's
necessarily a good thing.
There was a time when venture
capital was a scarce thing,
and the funds were fairly small.
And companies were going
into beg for money.
And now you have a situation
where there's so much money
that the venture
capitalists are competing
to get into the deals.
They're going and begging
at the entrepreneur's door.
That doesn't sound like a
recipe for good things, right?
If you have more money
chasing a few deals,
that's bound to
drive up valuations.
Suddenly the number of
unicorns went from eight to 145
in a matter of months.
And it's like they
can't really be that.
It's got to just be
there's too much money.
But I think another
argument people would make,
and it's probably
sensible, is that that's
how progress is made.
You throw a lot, a lot
of money at something.
And a lot of it goes flying
away and gets wasted.
And then some of it sticks
and makes the next Googles.
So I couldn't pretend
to be an expert on it,
but I do think there's a
lot more venture capital now
than there ever has been before.
I'm not so sure
that's a good thing.
Thank you very much for coming.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]